let's talk about the Spy balloon who who
quit who offered their resignation over
that that was a gross failure right that
was a gross failure shouldn't somebody
been fired they won't even admit that it
was a gross failure but but shouldn't in
the military someone should have come
forward and said I was responsible for
the the defense of our airspace it was
violated I failed I am quitting I'm
resigning because I failed to do my job
nobody's come forward to do that so
that's that's my concern is we don't
have that ethos now that that's
essential to the officer Corps that's
that's why I brought this whole
conversation up because like where's the
leadership but I can see like the end of
the Roman Republic Julius Caesar came
with the military and took control
military dictatorship Empire I don't
want that but that's what where my mind
is focused with a lack of leadership you
know what the hell's been happening last
month but I was Biden on East Ohio like
I want to I want to say this I'm
wondering we talk about morals and
ethics and uh often it's not black and
white there is there's a gradient to
what degree do we accept censorship or
oppose Free Speech uh even people who
say they claim to be free speech
absolutists I'm like you got a limit if
somebody is posting videos of child
exploitation you're probably gonna be
like okay yeah that's that's not speech
that's illegal it's like well it's not
and and that means you don't agree you
don't believe that anyone can just say
or produce anything they want there are
certain things that are illegal and then
even in so far as what if you're not a
producer of it you're sharing it for
some reason to express an idea no still
no you can't do that stuff so we accept
that there are limits in this regard
I wonder about I kind of lost my train
of thought what were we just talking
about we were talking about basically
when is it appropriate to resign the
ethics of you know a leadership and
whose accountability I thought was kind
of where we were going with this I'm
with I got you about Caesar
that was my biggest concern right
January 6th there was this narrative I
got it back I got it back okay I got it
back go yeah so my my issue is basically
we obviously don't like say like
Cambodia in the Kama Rouge The Killing
Fields whatever we see what happens when
brutal merciless dictatorships take over
the Soviet Union but I wonder if the
reason there's such a Negative view of
things like the Roman Empire is because
the people who were in those countries
who wrote down the stories of what
happened were the fat gluttonous
degenerates who were shocked to find
that a country was actually trying to
have some morals again what I mean to
say is it's not black and white there
are certainly circumstances where we're
like okay we got a problem with this
dictatorship and I'm sure there are
circumstances where you get a more
classically liberal but community-based
Stern attitude of service guarantee
citizenship that is to say a government
that doesn't come to you and lock you in
a gulag and mercilessly beat you a
government that comes and says I'm sorry
we're not going to pay your health care
because you're a glutton and you're
eating too much food you need to stop
well the gluttons the degenerates are
going to freak out they're going to
write every story in the world about how
the fascists are taking over and we're
watching this happen so if I saw
something
that was like service guarantee
citizenship if you want to vote you have
to provide some kind of community
service not military maybe it's picking
up trash the left is going to scream
fascism Fascism and I'm kind of like
doesn't that just mean personal
responsibility no one's telling you
you're going to prison no one's gonna
beat you can still speak you still play
video games you can still eat all the
hojos and Ding Dongs in the world but
we're saying you've got to be
responsible to the community around you
they would call that fascism so in the
event we did have a quote unquote
military takeover but I'm saying that
you know somewhat tongue-in-cheek I mean
quite literally if they came out and
said hey there's a minimum standard and
it's going to be this but you'll be able
to live your lives as you see fit the
people who are going to write the
history books are going to claim a
military dictatorship destroyed freedom
in this country when in reality it might
actually just be something like hey
we're about to collapse the country is
going to fall apart the economy is
spiraling out of control there's riots
in the street I'll give you a better
example if Donald Trump deployed the
military invoking the Insurrection act
during the summer of Love saving 30 plus
lives they would write down in the
history books a military dictator Donald
Trump suppressed free speech so I I
question these narratives throughout
history some of them are probably bad
some of them might not been might not
have been as as bad
the most recent um at least supposed
coup that almost tried to happen in our
country was supposed to be January 6th
um Chris you were um acting Secretary of
Defense at this time sixth in line for
the presidency so if some clue happened
I think it's sixth in line can somebody
fact check me out I believe it's six
months
um could you tell me a little bit more
about not your role in January 6th but
our reaction to it as I understand with
the National Guard careful with your
phrasing there uh you know and then also
we were talking about people resigning
there were a lot of people who resigned
from the Trump Administration following
this yeah
Sunshine soldiers for you know uh
you brought up if we would have since uh
soldiers up on Capitol Hill
on January 6 the morning of Jan so let's
go back I hate to do this let's go back
I'm going to be pedantic and talk about
our high school civics class Capitol
Hill legislative branch military
executive branch
Capitol Hill you don't go up there if
you're the Executive Branch the military
unless you're invited to do something
different is called a military coup so I
was not going to be party to that
obviously because that's Un-American in
violation of my oath of office to the
Constitution so this narrative that we
should have moved faster or have been up
there beforehand would have been could
you imagine what what would have
happened if we would have pushed if I
would have pushed National Guard troops
up on Capitol Hill before the riot
started wow it would have been a mess I
know the only person who got killed was
Ashley Babbitt by Capitol Police Officer
Michael bird
that was the only shot fired do you
think that was a justifiable shot given
the situation well you know the
Protective Service detail I I don't it
it appears to me that when she came
through the window that she by she
crashed in on the security bubble and
they and and uh they shot her that was
the moment when I realized we had been
promised that the police in Washington
DC and on Capitol Hill could handle up
to a million protesters that day and you
don't use your military for domestic law
enforcement cop that's what we have cops
for you don't use military you don't use
soldiers to do domestic law enforcement
until Civil Society is broken down like
a natural disaster in New Orleans
everything's gone to you know what
that's when you go in there that's when
the military serves and does uh law
enforcement duties until that happens
keep the military out the military you
talked about Vietnam military really
violated time tons of American civil
liberties by spying on Americans these
are the things that are still doing it
yeah my last follow-up was going to be
many people in the Trump Administration
decided to resign as a result of January
6th and the events following it you
chose not to can you tell me a little
bit more about that decision yeah
because I wanted to get more facts so
you know I had been in combat a day or
two I'd been a leader in the military
commander in the military and you don't
you got to be stable You Got to Be
steady right that's what good leaders do
I saw a lot of those political figures
that bailed that day doing it for
political reasons I was like we need to
find out what happened we're still
finding out what happened that day so
you know here's the one that always bugs
me when these bigwigs talk about well
you know I thought it would have been
the reason I stayed is because I had to
protect something I if it wasn't for me
you know I had to protect our soldiers
I'm not saying that that's not what I'm
saying I'm just saying that's my job I'm
gonna I got six weeks left or whatever
it was four weeks left and you know what
was that was it Thomas Paine Sunshine
soldiers what's that
yeah you know it's like hey you get paid
for the good times and the bad and you
really get paid for the tough times
that's what the American people pay for
right you never thought it was a coup or
anything
dude I was running the military there
was no coup okay because nobody was
right about that Millie's like you know
the only way there has to come through
us there was going to be no military
coup
dude I spent my life in service to this
country and I swore to protect and
defend the Constitution there's no way
that I was going to allow back to your
point about resigning if it came down to
that and the president was not about he
wasn't going there if it would have gone
there I would have resigned and gone
right outside and gotten on TV and said
I resigned in protest because I was
asked to do something uh
anti-constitutional period end of story
by him if he asked for you to bring
troops out if if he no if he wants if he
was going to use them inappropriately or
anti-constitutionally what about the uh
oh I forgot the date was it May 29th
when was the what was the Insurrection
yeah May 29th what about that
um you had these these uh far left as
setting fire to the to St John's Church
they set fire to a guard post the White
House they tore down barricades and the
response was police you know police came
out did their their normal thing I
suppose it's probably the appropriate
bonds
there were National Guard there that was
one remember you don't recall the the
national guard for the helicopters down
the middle of the streets uh that
evening oh gosh yeah there was uh a lot
went on that's not appropriate use of uh
the military I don't think so
no that's what you have local law
enforcement for that what what about
when they're not doing their jobs I mean
in Seattle and Portland we saw it was at
120 some odd days even New York they
were fired by the overwhelmed Federal
buildings for a hundred days father
extremists were throwing fire bombs and
explosives like at that point shouldn't
the Federal Government Act to defend its
territory like its building and like the
people who live and work in the area
federal government did they that put in
they didn't they put in huge numbers of
federal law enforcement to protect
Federal property the issue was the mayor
was on the left this side of the
spectrum and was allowing that to happen
it was a debacle and you've been out to
Portland lately oh my gosh but where but
all that really happened was federal law
enforcement stood inside the building
and then the leftists continued to
firebomb it for 100 plus days until they
got bored with it and stopped the the
feds did not actually come out feds were
all over that town don't you remember
the crisis that happened when uh how did
it go on for 120 days like why why did
it not stop I I believe in local
government I don't believe the federals
federal law enforcement should come in
without uh absolutely can protect
Federal property but the governor has
his National Guard his or her they had
plenty of access to uh security forces
and law enforcement and National Guard
without calling in the federal troops if
the federal government can't stop people
for three or four months from throwing
firebombs at its building then they
should probably just leave they
shouldn't be there because they're
completely impotent I I like the I know
they were there they did The Joint unit
they had DHS they had ice they had a
bunch of CBP or whatever we've been
coming and they could do nothing to stop
foreign
the city and firebombing their building
you can't do it you shouldn't you
shouldn't be there it was like they sent
troops into a Siege and then they just
had to sit there and be sieged for us
what was the point it's better than
having no troops in The Siege thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time